jetzt hat man es schwarz auf weiß es ist
die korona klatsche für team vorsicht
also für das team um karl lauterbach der
expertenrat der bundesregierung der
rechnet knallhart mit den pandemie
regeln habt das 18 köpfige
expertengremium sollte klären wie
wirksam die maßnahmen gegen die pandemie
eigentlich waren damit bund und länder
im kommenden herbst alte fehler nicht
mehr wiederholen heute wurde dieses
papier öffentlich vorgestellt und das
ergebnis ist wirklich ernüchternd lockt
da uns zum beispiel haben nur im
anfangsstadium einer pandemie eine
starke wirkung so die experten und je
länger ein locker und in kraft ist umso
schwerer wiegen die nicht beabsichtigten
schäden und auch die wirkung der
schulschließungen sehen die experten
äußerst kritisch und gerade eben ist
bundesgesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach dann vor die presse getreten
der minister ist weiterhin trotz dieses
papiers in alarmbereitschaft
wir sind am vorabend es von sehr sehr
schweren
herausforderungen die wir haben eine
wichtige sommer werde die jetzt begonnen
hat wir müssen davon ausgehen dass diese
sommer wäre uns lange begleiten wird wir
werden auch im herbst also eine
schwerere welle wahrscheinlich
bearbeiten müssen wir sind noch nicht im
zustand der ndb der aus einer erkrankung
angekommen wir haben den endemischen
zustand noch nicht erreicht daher haben
marco buschmann und ich stets minister
buschmann und ich wir haben schon die
vorbereitungen für die modifikation des
infektionsschutzgesetzes heute begonnen
wir haben eben schon anderthalb stunden
miteinander in guter atmosphäre sehr
konstruktiv an den neuen regelungen für
das infektionsschutzgesetz gearbeitet
werden diese arbeit in den nächsten
wochen sehr intensiv fortsetzen so dass
wir noch also in der zeit der nächsten
wochen hoffentlich zu einem guten
kompromiss kommen werden
weltpolitik chef jan schiffer ist bei
mir im studio an bevor wir über diesen
gesetzesentwurf sprechen ganz kurz etwas
skurril virologe hendrik strikt steht
quasi wie so ein bodyguard hinter karten
auch da war es sinnbildlich es gab heute
ja die evaluierung und das gutachten
über die korona maßnahmen
aus den vergangenen zwei jahren und
henrik strikt war teil dieser
präsentation und das ist natürlich nicht
üblich dass ein wissenschaftler wie du
jetzt sagen würdest wie ein schuljunge
hinter dem gesundheitsminister steht das
war sicherlich wie wir sehen hier auch
ein ein durchaus merkwürdiges bild aber
viel interessanter als das was karl
lauterbach gesagt hat in bezug auf den
kommenden herbst also wir sind noch
nicht in dieser ndb wie er sagt und
bereitet die bevölkerung ja seit wochen
eigentlich auch schon wieder auf eine
massive herbst welle vor wie auch immer
die dann comeback und ganz spannend ist
und das ist glaube ich auch ein
wichtiges thema gleich einmal zum
diskutieren das die gesundheitsminister
heute auch getagt haben also wenige
stunden nachdem die experten und du hast
es gerade gesagt ja die korona maßnahmen
zum teil wirklich verrissen haben haben
die gesundheitsminister getagt mit sehr
erstaunlichen ergebnissen orientieren
die sich dann an diesem papier des
gremiums was wir ja auch gerade
diskutiert haben oder ist das fernab von
gut und böse und dann macht jetzt wieder
sein eigenes ding was steht hier drin
genau wir haben einmal die
beschlussvorlage oder den
beschlussentwurf das sind insgesamt vier
seiten wir seiten bedruckt liegt jetzt
vor wird um 16.30 auch dann offiziell
präsentiert und dieser entwurf dieser
beschlussentwurf ist zu 60 mit 16 zu
null stimmen also von allen
gesundheitsministern der länder nach
unseren kenntnissen
abgenickt worden das heißt hinter diesem
beschluss der insgesamt neun punkte sind
es umfasst stehen also alle und diesen
beschluss geht es dann wieder um diese
klassischen maßnahmen die wir aus den
vergangenen zwei jahren kennen und mit
denen die experten ja nun heute wirklich
abgerechnet haben zum teil das ist das
pikante und brisante eigentlich also es
geht wieder um die frage masken pflicht
ganz klar da haben die experten heute
gesagt das hat sicherlich schon etwas
gebracht die masken pflicht und es geht
auch darum um zugangsbeschränkungen
beispielsweise zu pflegeeinrichtungen zu
haben aber es geht da natürlich auch
weiters ist auch wieder das die rede von
kapazitätsbeschränkungen oder sogar die
untersagung von veranstaltungen und des
betriebs von einrichtungen mit
publikumsverkehr das ist unter punkt 4
genannt das will man so gut es geht
vermeiden heißt es in diesem papier der
gesundheitsminister das haben wir aber
in den vergangenen monaten gerade im
letzten jahr auch immer wieder gehört
man wolle alles mögliche vermeiden und
dann heißt es aber in einem satz das
offenhalten von bildungseinrichtungen
hat oberste priorität gleichwohl müssen
auch diese instrumente also zum beispiel
kapazitäts begrenzung oder sogar das
schließen von einrichtungen also
gleichwohl müssen auch diese instrumente
der pandemie für cap bekämpfung im worst
case szenario zur verfügung stehen das
heißt schulschließungen kita
schließungen sind auch wieder im rennen
das bedeutet zumindest für einen in
einem wirklich schlimmen fall wenn aus
sicht der gesundheitsminister eine
überlastung des gesundheitssystems droht
wir wissen das sage ich auch ganz klar
das hat angeblich ja immer wieder
gedroht in den vergangenen zwei jahren
obwohl es dazu kam kann man streiten
warum es sich dazu kam und ob es jemals
gedreht aber wenn die
gesundheitsminister oder die
bundesregierung meint ist droht eine
überlastung dann kann es im ernsten und
im extremsten fall auch wieder sogar zu
schulschließungen kommen das geht
zumindest aus diesem papier jetzt hervor
wichtig das ist das papier der
gesundheitsminister das muss dann immer
noch mal insgesamt in einer so genannten
ministerpräsident konferenz
beispielsweise beschlossen werden aber
hier ist jetzt schon mal die erste
strecke würde ich sagen gelegt dann wird
diese konferenz sein das dauert jetzt
noch ein bisschen und die frage ist
kommt das zu einer konferenz wird es
möglicherweise auch im rahmen der
beratung über das infektionsschutzgesetz
schon einige maßnahmen gehen wieder auch
mit rein rutschen also das ist jetzt
noch nicht ganz klar wann es dazu kommt
aber faktum ist die gesundheitsminister
die haben es erst mal vorgelegt und
selbst wenn es eine mpk eine sogenannte
korona gipfelrunde dann im september
geben sollte und man die maßnahmen fest
legt dann ist es genauso verheerend für
viele wie also man das jetzt schon
festlegen würde ja nich hatten ich habe
auch in dieser gut in der tat man könnte
sich fast denken angela merkel ist
wieder bundeskanzlerin plötzlich es ist
es ist wirklich wie wir das papier liest
es hat sehr viel von einem nicht so
richtig schön dieser bestimmt besten
dank dir für deine einschätzung lernen